how many times have you had somebody say
to you hey have you got a minute but
you got a minute they don't want a
minute
i want you to think about that i read a
poem one time
i said i have only just a minute only 60
seconds in it
it was forced upon me i can't refuse it
i didn't seek it and i didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it i must
suffer if i lose it
give a count if i abuse it it's only a
tiny little minute
but eternity is in it well anyway
i thought i'm going to put this on a
video and i'm just going to share with
everybody just this one little part of
the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sand timer
and let this i want you to think about
your life
the sand in the top of the glass
represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past
now do you know we know what's in the
past and yet we can't do anything about
it
do you know what the trick is you don't
know how much sand's in the top of the
glass
you may think you have a lot you might
only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother and i don't know when i
was little gaffer she was probably 60
but
as long as i could remember grandmother
would say i'll soon be glenn dear i'll
soon be gone
well you know we loved her she was
really an angel of god but we thought
she was never going to go
she lived to be 94 for 30 some years
i'll soon be gone she didn't think she
had much time left she had 34
years left now about the same time
i had a buddy of mine bob yates he was
just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left
he would have said at least a half a
century he didn't have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future we don't know
the past it's gone now the only thing
you can deal with is what's right here
right now and if you look the sand is
always moving
now think of this you see i was working
on that
and then i was working on a graph i've
got here on my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute do
you know if you're earning 50
000 a year in minutes 42 cents
a half hour is 12.50
if we take that ahead a bit if you're
earning 80 000
a year a minute 67 cents half hours 20
dollars
if you're earning 150 000 a year got a
minute
it cost you a dollar 25 a minute a half
and hour's cents so if you see how
somebody said you want to stop for a cup
of coffee
well if you're earning a quarter of a
million dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hour is 62.50
and then of course you got the coffee to
pay for on top of that
so you see the point is this this is all
we've got
right here right now we don't know how
much we have left in the future but we
do know what we've got now and i have
found the people that win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen every minute
you tell yourself a lie often enough
you're going to start to believe it
and way around 1900 william james said
believe and your belief will create the
fact
it's got to be believed you've got to
believe it
and if there's no belief it ain't going
to happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea
and that makes all kinds of things
happen when you believe it
there's no quitting you never quit
it doesn't matter what happens you don't
quit
quitting is never an option
[Music]
i the people that quit
they never really bought into the idea
in the first place
see you've gotta you you get it on three
levels the second you think of something
you've got it intellectually
when you get emotionally involved you've
got it on a spiritual or emotional level
well then that expresses itself through
the body body's just an instrument of
your mind
and so when you're really buying into it
you literally fuse with it neville said
you fuse with it
and this causes all kinds of things to
happen
you're dealing with electronics you're
dealing with energy
like the second you think something
that's all you need see you live on
frequencies you think on frequencies
your phone operates on frequencies and
it's like magic
um you're you're in romania are you
right i'm in toronto
yes if i've got your number on my phone
i could take a picture or something hit
it
like that you've got it in romania
simultaneous with me sending it
because when you get into the mind there
isn't any time or space
it's just immediate yeah well
you're living on frequencies now when
you think of something
what you've done is you flipped your
brain onto a higher frequency
the very fact you can see it is all the
proof you need to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency
and then you will attract whatever's on
that frequency all the good you need to
manifest the idea
you should seek failures
see if you're playing it safe you're not
going to win
if you're playing it safe like that old
saying you know you're talking you're a
little girl
better to be safe than sorry well that's
a bunch of crap it's not better to be
safe than sorry
it's by trying things that you figure
out how far you can go
you've got to get outside the box like
it's reported edison
tried three thousand ways before he
built the incandescent light
he he said he didn't fail three thousand
times he said there was three thousand
different steps to building a light bulb
well there's different steps to get to
where you're going
and i really do treat winning and losing
exactly the same
i do not let it upset me do you think
that's a big part of why you're so
successful
well it's part of why i enjoy it
um yeah i think it is because i try
anything
like if if i'm into an idea the idea of
losing never enters my mind
see i have worked with giants
i had the good fortune of working with
sir edmund hillary
he was the first man to stand on top of
the world
and i worked with him on three different
occasions
and the only difference in ed hillary
and bob proctor is in his
his size now he's gone now but he was a
big man
he shook hands with me his hand wrapped
right around mine i felt like a
dwarf you know and
in talking to him like it never entered
his mind he wouldn't get to the top of
the mountain
but he failed in 1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain
now people had died for centuries trying
to do that
he said i knew if i could see it in here
i could hold it out here still a man
wrote that in the book you can see it in
your head you can hold it in your hand
and that's right and if you're not
prepared to lose
you're never going to win because you're
always playing it safe
and there's no there's no reward in that
why
most people don't get what they want out
of life
is it well they don't know what they
want that's right
you see i got this
and then i got earl nightingale's
condensed narration of this on a long
playing record
and i'd listen to that record over and
over and over again
one day i was in the business
in the cleaning business i had sales
people and
i had them listen to this record every
morning we listened to this record
and one day i said you know i'd love to
meet him
and i didn't know who earl nightingale
was he was a voice on a record that was
it i didn't even know where he lived
and a young guy that worked with me he
said no you wouldn't
he's if you wanted to meet him you'd go
and meet him i thought damn he's right
so i phoned and i got an appointment
with him
now at the time he was the most listened
to man in the history of the
broadcasting industry
he was a radio broadcaster and
not an easy guy to get to but i got to
meet with him for an hour
i flew to chicago i spent an hour with
him
and when i was leaving i said earl
what's the big deal you know i mean
what's it all about
he said she's no big deal he said it's
it's very simple he says simply decide
what you love to do and then dedicate
your life to it
he's the problem with most people they
don't know what they love to do they
never take the time to sit and ask
themselves
what they're doing is trying i think i
can get her in good money here i could
do a good
you know it's breaking the earn some
money it's not what they love to do
well i was sitting there now i had
offices all over the place i had a lot
of people i was earning a lot of money
and i i got excited because i knew
exactly what i wanted to do i'm going to
do what he was doing
and i made up my mind sitting in his
office
that would be somewhere around 1965
that i was going to go back and i was
going to work with him
and in 1968
i moved to chicago i left my own company
i moved to chicago and i started to work
with them
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days check the link right below
me and if you want more affirmations
from ed mylett
click on the video right there continue
to believe i'll see you soon